in this video you're going to learn how
to do some basic geometry constructions
involving a compass and a straight edge
you can use a ruler or any type of
straight edge and we're going to go
through about 14 different constructions
so let's start off with how do you copy
an angle and if you want to jump to any
particular type of construction look in
the description and I'll put time stamps
for all these different constructions so
when you copy an angle what you want to
do is you want to start off by drawing a
ray
and let's go ahead and draw that down
here and I tend to draw these rays and
these arcs a little bit larger or longer
than I think that I need this way you
don't have to go back and redo it later
so if we go up to our first angle here
what you're going to want to do is
you're going to want to put the point of
the compass right here at the vertex and
you're going to want to open up the
compass a certain amount and what you're
going to do is you're going to draw an
arc such that it crosses both sides of
the angle okay both Rays you're going to
take that compass with that same level
of opening you're going to put the point
on the vertex of that Ray and you're
going to draw that same
Arc okay and again like I said you want
to make it a little bit longer than you
think that you need now what you're
going to do is you're going to go over
to the first angle and you're going to
use the compass like a measuring tool
you're going to want to open it up in
such a way that it just you're measuring
from this point of intersection to this
point of intersection so let's see if we
can do that and I would just put a
little Arc here just to show that you
measured that on the first angle and
then go down here to the second angle
and go ahead and make that
that Arc now what you can do is you can
draw array from this point
and this intersection and that's going
to be copying the angle so let's go
ahead and do that
and that's it you've effectively copied
that angle so let's take a look at the
next Construction
let's take a look at how to draw a
perpendicular bisector so when you draw
a perpendicular bisector you're going to
have a segment and what you're going to
want to do is you're going to want to
open up your compass and you want to
make sure you open it up a little bit
more than half the length of this
segment so you just want to make sure
it's not less than half so a little bit
more than half is good and then what you
can do is you can put an arc above
the segment and an arc below the segment
or what some students like to do is just
draw one continuous Arc like so then
what you're going to want to do is
you're going to want to go to this other
endpoint and you're going to want to
draw using that same Arc
okay the compass is open the same amount
you're just going to want to draw
another continuous Arc or you can do two
separate arcs one above and one below
this segment then all you have to do is
use these two points of intersection
right here and right here to draw your
perpendicular bisector so let's go ahead
and do that
and you can see that this is a right
angle perpendicular you can also see
that it's bisecting or cutting this
segment in half
now we're going to talk about how to
copy a segment so when you copy a
segment this is kind of an easy
construction all you want to do is start
by drawing array
and again I make it a little bit longer
than I think I'm going to need
and then what you do is you use your
compass basically as a measuring tool so
what you're going to do is go to the
segment that you want to copy and you're
going to want to open it up to the
length from one endpoint to the other
end point so I would just make a little
Arc here just to show that you measured
that that length then take that Compass
over to your Ray and put the point at
the end point here and then draw an arc
like that and you've effectively copied
that segment so you can see that this
length is the same as this length and
you got it
in this next construction we're going to
construct a perpendicular from a point
to a line so remember the shortest
distance from a point to a line is going
to be at a right angle or perpendicular
so to do this construction what you want
to do is take your compass go ahead and
put the point right here at the the
point of the compass right at the point
and then you're going to want to open
your compass to a certain length so that
it crosses the
aligned at two different points so if
it's too short it's not going to Cross
or if it's just right you know you want
to make sure that it's just going to
cross at two points so basically we're
going to go ahead and draw one
continuous Arc you can do two separate
arcs if you want but I like to just do
one continuous Arc like that and so then
what you're going to do is you're going
to use these two points right here these
two points of intersection to draw two
more arcs so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to use this point here I'm
going to open up the compass a little
bit
more okay and I'm going to draw an arc
I'm going to go to this other point here
on the line draw an arc and now what we
can do is we can draw a line through
this point and this point of
intersection here and that's going to be
our our perpendicular from the point to
the line so let's go ahead and do that
and that's it you can see that that's
going to be a right angle
for this next construction we're going
to talk about how to construct a line
through a point parallel to a given line
so say this is line L say this is point
p and what we want to do is we want to
draw a line through this point parallel
to line L so what we're going to do is
we're going to draw a point anywhere
along line L I'm just going to draw a
point right here and what we're going to
do is we're going to draw a line
through those two points now you could
draw it as array if you want I'll just
I'll draw it as a ray here
okay and so then what you're going to
want to do is we're going to do just
like we did earlier where we copied an
angle so I'm going to copy this angle
right here up to right here and we're
making use of the corresponding angles
converse theorem if you learned that but
if not here's what you're going to do
you're going to go over here to this
vertex and I would draw an arc
and if you have any trouble with
you know using a compass or a straight
edge check out my video about how to use
a compass that'll help you with some of
the techniques here because sometimes
when students do this they their Compass
opens up on them or the compass skips or
you know there's all kinds of different
issues students have but as far as just
using this these tools but here what you
can see is I copied this Arc over to
here so all we're going to do is be copy
this angle and so what I'm going to do
now is I'm going to use the compass as a
measuring tool to see how open this
angle is so I'm going to measure this
distance right here
and I'm going to carry that over to here
draw an arc and now all we have to do is
draw a line through this point and then
this point of intersection right here so
let's go ahead and do that
and you can see this line M we'll call
it is parallel to line L and then again
that's because of the converse or the
corresponding angles theorem
okay for our next construction we're
going to talk about how to bisect an
angle so this is the angle here that we
want to bisect or cut in half and so
what you're going to want to do here is
you're going to want to take the point
of your compass put it at the vertex of
the angle open up your compass and then
draw an arc such that it intersects both
sides of the angle then we're going to
use these two points right here and here
to draw two more arcs so I'm going to
draw an arc like so go to the other
point of intersection on the side of the
angle draw another Arc like so and now
all we have to do is draw a ray through
the vertex of the angle and then this
point of intersection here and that's
going to effectively bisect the angle so
let's go ahead and do that
and that's it you can see that this
angle here and this angle here are
congruent to one another
for this next construction we're going
to talk about how to draw a square
inscribe inside of a circle so in order
to do this construction what we're going
to do is we're going to start off by
drawing a diameter now remember a
diameter is a chord
that goes through the center of the
circle so just go ahead and locate the
center of your circle draw a chord
okay such that it goes through that
Center Point and then what we're going
to do now is we're going to find the
perpendicular bisector of this diameter
so in order to find the perpendicular
bisector we're going to use the
endpoints of the diameter I'm going to
open up the compass a little bit more
than halfway and we're going to draw an
arc above and below that diameter or
what you can do is just draw one
continuous Arc so that's what I'll do
here go to the other endpoint of the
diameter and go ahead and draw
an arc above and below the diameter or
you can draw one continuous Arc and now
what we're going to do is we're going to
go ahead and draw that perpendicular
bisector using these two points of
intersection so let's go ahead and do
that
and you can see
it's going to cross the circle
at these two points right here and here
so now all we have to do is connect
these four points and we're going to
have a square that's inscribed inside of
a circle now remember inscribed scribe
means to write or Draw N means like it's
on the inside or the interior of the
circle whereas circumscribed like in
this case the circle is circumscribed
meaning a circle means like a round or
about
the square so let's go ahead and draw
that
and you can see it there we go our
square is inscribed meaning the vertices
lie right on the circle and it's on the
inside of the circle
for this next construction we're going
to talk about how to circumscribe a
circle about a triangle so in order to
do this construction we're going to need
to construct a minimum of two
perpendicular bisectors of the sides of
this triangle now I might end up drawing
all three let's we'll see how this goes
but let's go ahead and start with this
line segment here okay this side of the
triangle we're going to draw a
perpendicular bisector which we did
earlier in this video so what we're
doing is just kind of stacking Concepts
here so remember open up that Compass a
little bit more than halfway
okay and if I go to the other endpoint
of the side of the triangle and draw
another Arc
and what we're going to do now is we're
going to use those two points of
intersection where those two arcs cross
and that's going to be our perpendicular
bisector now what you're going to want
to do is again like I've mentioned
earlier you're going to want to draw
these a little bit longer than you think
you need because it really saves you
some time and aggravation with having to
go back later and trying to extend some
of those lines so that's our first
perpendicular bisector I'll just
indicate that here so it's bisecting
that side let's go to this other side
over here now and draw the perpendicular
bisector so what I'm going to do is
again I'm going to open up the compass a
little bit more than half
way and I'm going to draw one continuous
Arc such that it goes above
and below
that that side of the triangle go to the
other endpoint
and go ahead and draw an arc that same
same Arc okay and now what we're going
to do is we're going to use those two
points of intersection which are let's
see where is that right here
and right here
to draw
our perpendicular bisector so you can
see that's at a right angle and it's
cutting this segment over here in half
and let's just do one more let's go
ahead and use
this third side here that we haven't
worked with yet let's go ahead and draw
the perpendicular bisector of that one
it's getting a little bit chaotic here
as you can see so because of all the
lines but see if you can follow this I'm
going to draw one continuous Arc
such that it goes above and below that
goes above and below that
that line and then go to the other end
point and draw another
continuous Arc such it goes above and
below that line and then now when we go
and draw
the perpendicular bisector here
let's see that's right about here
you can see that's perpendicular and
it's bisecting that side and what we're
looking for here now is where do all
these three perpendicular bisectors
cross well let's see it looks like
here's one
here's one here's one they're roughly
crossing right about
here okay so that point is called our
circumcenter that's where the three
perpendicular bisectors cross and so now
what we're going to do is we're going to
take our Compass put the point at that
circumcenter that we just mentioned and
what we're going to do is we're going to
open up the compass so that it just
barely reaches to one of the vertices
but what you'll notice it's going to be
the same distance to all three vertices
okay so let's go ahead and draw now a
circle
around
the triangle so we're circumscribing
okay or drawing a circle around the
triangle such that the vertices lie
right on the circle now you can see my
drawing was pretty good you can see this
is touching here this is touching here
this is touching here now a question
your teacher might ask you and these
types of problems is what do you know
about this length or this length
or this length well you can see these
are the radii of the circle so they're
all going to be congruent they're all
going to be the same length so that's
how you circumscribe a circle about a
triangle
okay for our next construction we're
going to talk about how to inscribe a
circle inside of a triangle so again
stacking Concepts we talked about this
earlier in this video about how to
bisect an angle we're going to find the
three angle bisectors of this triangle
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go to this vertex here we're going to
draw an arc
and then we're going to use those two
points of intersection to draw two more
arcs I just keep the compass at the same
opening
and then we're going to go ahead and
draw
a line that or I should say array from
this vertex through this point of
intersection and I'll just draw it
to the other side of the triangle so you
can see that's bisecting that angle or
cutting that angle in half we're going
to go over here to this other angle and
we're going to bisect that angle so
let's go ahead and draw an arc
okay and then we're going to use those
two points of intersection and we're
going to draw two more arcs
so like that
and like that and then we're going to
use that point of intersection and the
vertex excuse me to draw a ray so let's
go ahead and do that
so you can see that this angle is being
bisected or cut in half
now you could do that again on the third
angle excuse me and you'll find out that
they're going to all cross at the same
point here and this point here is What's
called the the in Center
of the triangle
now what's interesting about the in
Center that means that's going to be the
center of a circle that can be inscribed
inside of the triangle but what we need
to do now is we need to find the
perpendicular distance from this point
to this side or this point to this side
or this point to this side doesn't
matter which one let's just go ahead and
do uh let's say from this point to this
side so we talked about this earlier in
this video how to draw a perpendicular
from a point to a line you're going to
want to open up your compass so that
when you draw an arc it crosses the side
of that triangle at two points okay then
you're going to use these two points
here to draw two more arcs and I just
would leave the compass open at the same
amount of opening there for both of
these
okay and then all we have to do now is
draw a line from this point to this
point of intersection right
right here okay so let's go ahead and do
that
and so you can see what we've drawn is
this is a
perpendicular which means it's the
shortest distance from this point to
this side of the triangle now we're
going to treat that as the radius of our
Circle so we put the point of the
compass at this in Center Point right
here we're going to open up the compass
so that it just barely touches
at where we drew that perpendicular to
the side of the triangle and that's
going to be the radius of our Circle so
now what we're going to do is we're
going to inscribe or Draw
our Circle
inside of our triangle
okay so let's see how we did so you can
see that it just it just barely
touches the side of the triangle so the
sides of the triangle are basically like
uh tangents to the circle now here you
can see I went a little bit over and
that's because some of my drawings might
have been not exactly perfect so my
construction so that's why I went a
little bit over but if you take your
time it should be exact and then what
your teacher will oftentimes ask you is
what do you know about this
perpendicular distance and this
perpendicular distance well they're all
going to be congruent because they're
the radii of this circle and so you'll
if you know this length you're going to
know these other two lengths but again
this point is the in center it's where
the three angle bisectors cross and then
you can inscribe the circle inside of
the triangle
okay for this next construction we're
going to talk about how to inscribe a
regular hexagon inside of a circle so
how do we do this construction well what
you want to do is you're going to start
with a circle and what I would do is I'd
open up your compass so that you go from
the center of the circle to a point on
the circle that's going to be your
radius now with that same level of
opening you're going to take your point
of your compass and you're going to put
it at that point on the circle and
you're going to make arcs working your
way around
the circle so I'm just rotating the
circle putting the point at the next
point of intersection draw another Arc
just keeping that Compass open the same
distance working your way around the
circle drawing those congruent arcs
okay and so now what you want to do is
you want to connect
each of these points and that's going to
form a regular hexagon so let's go ahead
and do that
see what we get here
should be a perfect hexagon regular
hexagon where all the sides are
congruent all the angles are congruent
let's see how this is looking here
now you can also do this exact same
Construction
and create a
an equilateral triangle an equilateral
equal angular like a regular triangle
and the way that you would do that is
you would use every other
point so I'd Skip One go to the next one
Skip One go to the next one Skip One go
to the next one so if we do that we can
inscribe an equilateral equiangular
triangle inside of this
Circle sometimes you'll do that
construction instead of the hexagon one
in your class
let's see what that looks like
so some pretty interesting designs there
now let's take a look at another
Construction
okay for this construction we did one in
the last construction with an
equilateral triangle but this is a
little bit different if we want to
construct an equilateral triangle with
this given side length right here how
would you do that well what you do is
you use your compass again like a
measuring tool you're going to want to
open it up so that it just barely
reaches to the other
end point like that and I would just
draw an arc to show that you measured
that then what you're going to want to
do is you're going to want to draw an
arc
like this and again remember how I tend
to draw them a little bit longer than I
think I need okay that's and then go to
the other end point with that same level
of opening of your compass draw another
Arc
and then what you can do you see this
point right here we're gonna
connect these endpoints of the original
line segment the original side of the
triangle
and that's going to form an equilateral
equiangular triangle
and you got it
okay in this next construction we're
going to talk about how to copy an
entire triangle using the side angle
side so how do we do that well the first
thing we want to do is we want to draw
array and again what I would do is I
would draw that Ray a little bit longer
than you think you need and this end
point here let's call that a prime and
so what we're going to do is we're going
to start off by copying this side of the
triangle AC onto this array and we
talked about this a little bit earlier
in this video about how to copy a
segment you just use the compass as a
measuring tool you open it up so it just
barely reaches this point here
Point C and I just draw a little Arc to
show I measure that and then go ahead
and carry that over here onto the ray
and so then where that intersection is
right here this is going to be our point
C Prime and you can see that a Prime C
Prime is congruent to AC okay now what
we're going to do is we're going to copy
this angle a onto this point here a
prime so what we're going to do is we
talked about this earlier as well how to
copy an angle you're going to use your
compass
to draw an arc such that it crosses
both sides of the angle and we're going
to use the compass with that same level
of opening go ahead and carry that over
to this
Ray
okay and again I would draw that Arc a
little bit longer than you think you
need then what you're going to do is
you're going to go to the original angle
here a and we're going to measure from
here to here we're going to use the
compass as a measuring tool
and I'm just going to make a little Arc
right here
and I'm going to carry that over
I'm going to make an arc right here now
all I have to do is draw array
through a prime and that point of
intersection and again I would make it a
little bit longer than you think you
need
like that straw array and so now you can
see that this angle and this angle are
congruent so that's our side angle and
now we just have to do one more side is
we're going to copy this segment a b
onto this Ray so again we talked about
this earlier how to copy a segment
you're just going to use the compass as
a measuring tool so you open that up
okay a little bit more
right about right about there and you're
going to carry that over here
and so now you can see here's your B
Prime
so you can see that a b segment a b is
congruent to segment a prime B Prime now
if we connect these together
what do we have here
we've got it so you can see that this
triangle is congruent to this triangle
by side angle side side angle side and
you got it
okay for this next construction we're
going to talk about how to copy a
triangle using side side sides remember
three sides in one triangle are
congruent to three sides in another
triangle then that means that the two
triangles are congruent so I'm going to
start off by just drawing a ray
and again remember I just want to draw
that Ray a little bit longer than we
think that we need and what we're going
to do is we're going to copy this
segment here A B onto that Ray so we
talked about how to copy a segment we're
just going to open up the compass
I use it as a measuring tool so it just
barely reaches B here
see if I can get that a little bit more
accurate so basically like like that we
come over here
okay and so now you can see if this is
our a prime add this over here would be
our B Prime and we know that these two
segments are congruent okay so now what
do we need to do now we need to copy
another side so how can we copy another
side well let's go ahead and
look at the length of BC here so I'm
going to use the compass again as a
measuring tool so put the point at one
of the endpoints of the side put your
pen or pencil at the other end point
and what we're going to do is we're
going to carry that over to B Prime here
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
draw an arc
bigger than I need okay it's okay to
have it bigger than you need you can
always go back and erase some of the
extra if it's too big and then what
we're going to do now is we're going to
also look at the length of AC here okay
AC and so I'm going to use the compass
again as a measuring tool okay so I'm
going to open that up right here
AC and I'm going to go over here to a
prime
and I'm going to
draw an arc now you can see those arcs
are intersecting right here at this
point so what we can do now is we can
draw the other two sides of our triangle
so we've got
from here to here
and also from here
to here
and that's it so you can see that this
is the location of uh C Prime so you can
see that b c and b Prime C Prime are
congruent a c and a Prime C Prime are
congruent and we prove the two triangles
congruent by side side side side side
okay before we do this last construction
of copying a triangle using the angle
side angle if you want to see like maybe
where I got some of these tools from
I'll put some links some Amazon links in
the description below so you can check
those out if you need to get a hold of
any of these tools that I'm using here
but let's dive into this last example
here so what you would do to copy the
triangle is you would start by drawing a
ray and again remember our rule for
drawing rays and arcs try to draw them a
little bit longer than you need
okay you'll thank yourself later and so
here's your array and let's just call
this point w
Prime okay so that's going to be our new
point w now to do angle side angle let's
start off by copying this angle W to W
Prime so how do we do that well we
talked about this earlier in this video
we know how to copy an angle we start by
drawing an arc such that it intersects
both sides of the angle we go ahead and
carry that over here to W Prime and make
that a little bit longer than we think
we need
a little bit further like that okay now
what we're going to do is we're going to
measure how open this angle is we're
going to measure the distance from here
to here now we just Mark that with a
little Arc to show that you measure that
same thing over here
and now all we have to do is draw array
from W Prime through that point of
intersection again drawing it a little
bit longer than you think that you might
need
okay like that and so now you can see
that this angle W and W Prime they're
congruent to one another okay so that's
the angle part now let's do the side so
let's look at the side Wy so Wy to copy
a segment we talked about that earlier
in the this video we just have to use
the compass as a measuring tool open it
up so that it barely reaches the other
endpoint
draw an arc to show that you measure
that carry that over to
this Ray
okay and that's going to be the location
of Y Prime okay so our new y so now you
can see that this segment is congruent
to this segment so that's the side now
we have to show the the other angle so
angle side angle so we have to copy
angle y over onto y Prime so we know how
to copy an angle we just start by
drawing an arc such that it intersects
both sides of the angle let's go ahead
and draw that over here
okay like so
a bit longer than you think you need and
we're going to measure how open this is
so we're going to measure from here
to
here
that over here
okay
and now all we have to do is draw array
from y Prime
through this point of intersection
and you can see this is going to be our
new X Prime so we copy that angle
so you can see we've got it we've got
our angle side angle angle side angle
and that proves that both of these
triangles are congruent to each other
and you got it so great job if you want
to see some more videos that I did
talking about constructions I'll put a
link to a playlist of my geometry
constructions at the on the screen now
and if you want to check out those I'll
see over in those videos talk to you
soon